PROFESSOR: So
typically in the course
we start off talking
about the structure
of these cellular materials.
We do some modeling of honeycomb
and foam type materials,
and that takes not
quite half the term,
but most of the first
part of the term anyway.
And I give them
more problem sets
at the beginning of the
term, and they don't really
start on the projects
at the beginning.
So I give them some background
information to get them going.
And I assign the project at
the beginning of the course,
and I think there's
three kind of deadlines.
One is they have to
give me a proposal.
I think that's typically
about a month into the course,
and that can be
fairly brief, but I
want to at least know
they've got a team.
They've got an idea.
They've got some idea
of how they're going
to carry out their project.
Then in about another
month they have
to send me a sort of update on
the project, and by that point,
I would have expected them,
if they're doing a literature
review, to start
reading some papers
and be able to tell me
something about the background
to their project.
If they're doing
experiments, I would
have expected them to at
least gone into the lab
and maybe made some materials,
or bought some materials,
and done some preliminary tests.
And I give them
feedback at that point.
And at the end of the term,
they hand in the final project.
And I see them twice
a week in class,
and I don't really have a formal
recitation, but what I do do
is every week that a problem
set is due I have office hours.
And in fact, I don't actually
have it in my office.
I book a room, and we
do a little tutorial.
So there's times
throughout the term
they can see me and come
and ask me questions
about the project as well.
So the question is what kind of
feedback do I give the students
and how do they interact
with me on the projects,
and typically there's about 20
students that take the course.
So if they do it in pairs,
there's roughly 10 projects.
Some of the projects students
just do literature searches,
and I don't really get
that involved with those.
They're perfectly capable
of going to the library
and doing a literature search.
And some of the students
who are taking it
are graduate students, and
they often do finite element
numerical calculations.
And again, I give them some
advice about how to set it up,
but often they have
experience doing this,
and it's sort of applying
what they already
know to something new, but
they kind of know what to do.
The way I get the most
involved is if students
do experimental projects.
So for instance, in this
elephant skull project,
I had this connection at the
Museum of Comparatives Zoology,
and I took the student up there.
They had this idea
about 3D printing it,
and we have a 3D printer
in the department.
And one of the technical
staff, Mike Tarkanian,
is very, very good
with the students
and very helpful in getting
them set up on the 3D printer,
so he helps with that.
And I give them sort
of general advice.
When they said now
we want to measure
some sort of
acoustical response,
I suggested maybe
you could suspend it
from a wire, or
thread, or something
and then put an accelerometer
and measure the vibrations.
So I try to give them some
general advice like that,
but they then carry the
experiment out themselves.
They have to figure out how to
actually put it into practice
and how to do it.
And I think they get a
big kick out of that.
MIT students enjoy that kind
of thing so that's kind of fun,
and obviously I was
very delighted too
with this elephant
skull project.
So there's different
things I try
to help with-- mostly giving
general advice about how
they can do their
experimental projects.
So what are some
of the challenges
that students encounter
in their projects.
So I think one thing is
students sometimes are
little over ambitious in
what's possible to accomplish,
because typically we have to
cover some material before they
can even start the project.
So typically they
don't start the project
until a month or six
weeks into the term,
and the term is only three
months long more or less.
And so they really have a fairly
limited amount of time-- maybe
six weeks or eight
weeks, something
like that-- to actually
do the project.
So if they want
to make materials,
if they want to do some sort
of processing to make a foam,
for example, they don't
really have a lot of time,
because often it takes
some trial and error
to be able to do that.
So the projects have
to be fairly focused
so that they can actually get
something interesting out of it
in a fairly short
amount of time.
And sometimes
students might want
to do something where they
would have to order materials,
and it may take a few weeks
for the materials to come in.
So again, I try
to discourage them
from doing projects where
there's going to be a long lead
time on getting some
critical thing that they
need for the project.
So there are some limitations,
partly because of just the time
we have for them
to actually do it.
And they're not just
taking my course.
They're taking other
courses, so there's
sort of a limited amount of
time they can spend on it, too.